- So a Texas church is almost
certainly gonna get sued
for an illegal performance
of the play "Hamilton"
because they did it without authorization
and added a whole bunch
of anti-gay messaging.
♪ My hope is in Jesus ♪
- This play is bad.
♪ No ♪
- Extremely bad.
♪ New York ♪
- And it's almost certainly
copyright infringement.
But as the original
playwright, Lin-Manuel Miranda,
said, it's never okay to change the words,
lyrics, or notes without
their express consent,
except that sometimes it is.
Sometimes, commentary
and criticism requires
that you change the word
of someone else's IP,
and these rules can't change
whether you like the message or not.
In fact, in the seminal case on fair use,
Campbell v. ACUFF-ROSE,
the rap group 2 Live Crew
changed the words to Roy
Orbison's song "Pretty Woman."
♪ Big hairy woman ♪
- [Devin] And it was considered parody,
and it was considered fair use.
♪ You need to shave that stuff ♪
- Now, that probably doesn't apply here.
This looks like straight-up
copyright infringement.
It doesn't seem like it's a parody.
But that being said,
parody doesn't require you
to agree with the message, and
it's an argument to be made.